no less moving at a pretty sweet teaser
trailer a wrinkle in time so a wrinkle
in time is a Disney movie where this
girl's dad essentially disappeared he
was theorizing how to travel across the
known universe in an instant born as he
disappeared four years ago and now these
galactic deity type ladies come to this
girl and her brother and they were like
let's find her - that's essentially the
premise of the movie movies pretty
aimless so I used the word essentially
when the hell is talking about from the
beginning of this movie this movie just
was not grabbing me the movie didn't get
me connected to the characters I mean I
get the concept her dad's gun she's
rebelling you get that her father's done
you get what she's feeling but you just
yeah it doesn't hit you where you live
don't know what to say in a movie
properly illustrating that is important
for an adventure like that and when they
go on this adventure with these three
deity type ladies they go to these
wondrous wonderful looking lands they're
just like oh they hang out here alright
let's go to the next one and they do
that it's just kind of a hop skip and a
jump because that's the point of the
movie you feel like these worlds are
Disney with their fingers crossed going
alright if this movie takes off it makes
a lot of money we can bring that world
to our new Disneyland theme park and you
genuinely feel like that's the point of
the movie if you focus this movie up
this movie would be about 40 minutes
long do you feel like they just had to
draw it out for the sake of filling time
i wrinkle it I'm not even going to and I
know this movies based off a little book
with this a book I know nothing about
it's a book I've never read all I can do
is base the movie on the movie this
movie has a sweet message about love and
love connecting people I mean it is
cheesy but it's a Disney movie for kids
really I feel like Ava Duvernay was on a
roll with these low-budget character
pieces then she got a big budget from
Disney and it kind of shows why she
should stick with low-budget character
pieces she's finding that wheelhouse
it's like Shyamalan should not have a
big budget I feel like she might be in
that same boat and I remember in the
movie the main girl and the older boy
not her little brother but the older kid
they're having a moment he says
something like I don't think you know
how wonderful you are or something like
that it's like their lines were written
by adults through the eyes of adults but
they're supposed to be kids but kids
don't talk like that so there's just it
conflicts with me like kids be kids I
mean the really smart kid he talks a
little different because I'm supposed to
be smart but I want to give that little
kid a pass because he is a little kid
but there's a point in the movie where
the movie requires much more of him
happens in the movie I guess I don't
want to spoil it for you in case you
want to watch it but if what happened
with this kid happened earlier in the
movie we're giving it some emotional
weight but is it stance it just kind of
happens you're like okay I guess I guess
this is happening now and then the movie
requires so much more of this kid and
the kid just was not up to the task I
mean in a world where he's a kid in 2018
there's like a 10 or 20 percent chance
that he might actually watch his review
yet if you're watching this stick with
it man I want to see you have a feature
in acting but it doesn't change the fact
that the kid was not up to the task he
could not deliver what the role required
of him at that point it's on Ava
Duvernay or whatever producer from
Disney said yeah he's the kid for this
task he was gonna be on him and they
essentially took a level six rogue
through him up against a level 60 dragon
said alright it's you that sucks I feel
like I failed him and it actually
compromised the entire movie as a whole
because the emotional weight was on the
moments between the kid and her and when
it doesn't come together the movie
doesn't deliver just the whole thing
falls apart guys in the end this movie
had interesting concepts I mean if
you're looking for a movie that's like
oh it's about space-time it's really not
it's not really the basis of it just
essentially it's a fantasy adventure
saying a wrinkle in time is a movie
about space-time is like saying
hurricane Isis movie about meteorology
it's it's not why it's there it just
uses that as a platform to send these
kids on an adventure but really this
adventure was quite messy
it was unfocused the characters didn't
resonate with me I feel like Ava
Duvernay bit off a bit more than she
could chew with this one she should
probably do the character pieces like
Selma she was great at that as for a
wrinkle and I'm not gonna remember it in
t-minus one day yep already forgot but
Disney if you want to send people to an
Adventureland I could really go for that
third Tron movie that you cancelled that
he talks about this is not happening
ever I want a Tron trilogy soon right so
wrinkle in time have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you
[Music]